real quickly so where did you meet the
gentleman that you collaborated on the
film with remember where that was
physically or yeah that was in yeah
there was a car it's funny I think what
happened is I think I went to an NYU
alumni gathering which is one of those
things like you know I think all schools
do that that if you if you're a film
school and you come out to LA you know
and you're floating in limbo like you
are coming to one of these events and
all your fellow straggle you know limbo
you know people trying to find a job
will get together and you're bound by
this NYU thing common thing and all I
remember is meeting if a former NYU
graduate and he said oh you should meet
this guy because he and even at that
time I was kind of worried about being
dependent on a studio or a networker
giving me a job I mean it already felt
normally competitive all I had was and
was my thesis film you know I wasn't
going to get picked to direct aliens or
something it wasn't that but I wasn't
gonna happen and I started to think of
her I started to think independently I
was like well look I've got to
demonstrate that I know that I
demonstrate that I can make a feature
film to myself and anybody else so I
can't wait on somebody giving me a fee
money for a feature film so I got to
figure out a way to do this and he was
like oh well that's because so many
people are like well you know it's
studio no I'm only gonna make 50 million
dollar movies and I'm gonna spend the
next ten years in development and then
it's like I never had the patience for
that I was and I guess I was a bit of a
pessimist I was like look I'm gonna have
to do this somehow am I on my own we're
realists yeah or yeah just be or yeah
and I just was like okay how do I do
that well I don't have dumb money but
this guy did this guy had the money at
least a modicum of money right on the
credit card and he had the the will his
name was his name was Mick wine Hawke
and and Mick was like I'm gonna do this
and I think he was suffering from the
same sort of fatigue that all of us he
had been coming as an actor he had been
trying to get parts and stuff and had
God had some success but he was getting
frustrated like this is going nowhere no
one's gonna give me a lead part so I
need to come up with a way where I can
get a lead part
well I'll produce a movie I'll pay for
it that'll guarantee me this lead part
and he had the strength and the he had
the smarts enough to put the thing
together he's the one who got Danny
Bonaduce but he still needed someone
like myself to write and direct it and
bring more cast and more crew and bring
that and so it was a good you know as a
classic collaboration he had these
resources but he needed this he needed
this from me and I needed someone to
bankroll my first feature so that's
that's how that happened but we met at a
coffee shop that's not existing it's too
bad there's no more coffee shops there
was a coffee shop on the corner of
LaBrea and it's at La Brea and Santa
Monica it's where the best buy is now
cameras at La Brea Highland I think it
might be Highland and that's what we
meant we got together and we started
talking
we've met there and we kept coming back
there with you know for creative ideas
you know just batting stuff around then
I went off and wrote the thing and we
just made it did you almost say no do
you remember something remember when he
told you and you left that coffee shop
and what your process was and how you
almost made me didn't make it and what
talked you into doing it no one had to
talk me into it no you were I was like
yes okay because he had that he had that
thing we're talking about which is just
he had the money right okay I had the
money you know like everything else was
and yes there there's certainly
limitations I mean maybe I would not
have elected to make an exploitation
movie as my first feature
maybe I certainly would not have elected
to make it on video but those things
were the things that created sort of the
stimulus for the idea in other words
those having no parameters I think is
harder than having some like or
limitations let's look at them as
limitations if somebody says you can
make anything you want I don't care what
the subject matter is and the sky's the
limit for the budget I think you're
gonna have a harder time I mean unless
yes you may we're all nursing these
epics that we want to make but if
someone says you can have anything you
want or it's like one of those questions
like you you just won that blotter it
you've just won one hundred million
dollars what are you gonna buy it's
almost like you're but if somebody says
no you have to do this within this
particular box I think it those walls
which can be walls or limitations
sometimes are good things because you
now have an arena within which to work
and it's not just the entire universe
it's this so shooting on video having
somebody get killed every five pages or
whatever those things were nudity all
those and you know all those things were
like okay well now I had those are the
elements that I have to deal with and it
made it a little bit easier for me to
come up with the with the story but no I
never had a second because I was so
desperate I mean it's like anybody who
comes out here I tell my students this
it's like when you go out to LA it's
like I don't even remember the first
like year and a half of living in LA
just because it was so stressful it was
so right and I'm not trying to scare
anybody because this is the way it is I
mean you could I know people who come to
LA and they got a job in the first month
I was like I envy that but for me it was
like I don't know anybody I can't get
arrested right I don't you know all
those and that starts unless you're like
have our super thick skin which I don't
think a lot of us have I think you
developed that or you get crushed like I
think artists in general creative people
actors directors writers generally are
very sensitive people because you have
to be in order to do that thing like an
insensitive cold shut off from their
emotion director actor is not going to
do any interesting work I think so I
think most of us tend to be whatever
facade we put on are very vulnerable
frightened emotional people and when you
come and you when you put that up
against a business which does not give a
which is one of the most ruthless
you know doesn't give a business
and I know there are plenty of other
businesses but this place and the other
thing is that this business and you are
in Hollywood plays with your dreams I
mean that's the thing it's like it's
it's it's self it's a self titled dream
factory where if you hit the right
combination your dreams will come true
I don't think people go to even if they
get involved in a competitive business
that's not necessarily doesn't tap into
that part of your brain about dreams
making your dreams happen so if you're
like in this state of vulnerability
anyway and it's all about if you do the
right thing your dreams will come true
it makes you a very fragile person so I
think most of us are looking for any way
to take a tiny step up from where you
are which most of us are somewhere
hovering in the lower depths and we want
to step up let's so when this guy said
hey come to Wisconsin and make sure you
write me a good part but I'll pay for it
I was like of course definitely
I'll go I'm going to Wisconsin I thought
I would yeah I didn't know I was ready I
was I was desperate desperate and and
ready I was like okay good good now I
can did you envision that you'd be
taking meetings and driving around in a
red Ferrari after it was done or did you
also say this is a stepping stone this
isn't the million dollar jackpot yeah I
think no I for me sort of the you know
the sports car and all that that stuff
never was a big that was never a
priority I think most of us just want to
work and keep working and yes would like
to be paid to keep working I mean that's
I think that's the dream all the other
stuff I mean sure I'm sure
other people have the dreams of the you
know the mansions and the servants and
the blonde bimbo on your arm and all
that junk to me it was just like serving
that thing which it's like an addicts
thing I think I've said this before it's
like a being a drug addict you you have
this need to do this thing which is make
films it's very difficult to just open
up this person banking a bag of money
it's to to support this thing you were
reliant on others I just wanted to keep
working so but I did hope that the film
would be perceived in a way so that I
would be easier for me to get another
job that's what I wanted I didn't want
yes I mean yes I would love
to get discovered and win Sundance and
all those fantasies that we all have but
I just wanted someone to look at me
differently and say oh you've made a
feature which funny enough going back to
what you were saying at the time in 1991
there wasn't as many independent
features being made so there was a
certain perception that went along with
somebody who had actually made it in the
independent feature whether it was you
know good or bad it was like well he
actually climbed that mountain he
actually went out and did it so that
that was helpful
it did get some nice reviews and it did
open some doors for me certainly it
didn't press the magic you're now a star
and now the sky's the limit I still I
still was down there but I was a step up
where I was sure well even just going
back to then and would story yeah which
I don't know I'm not there's not you
know I parallels I'm sure there's a lot
of family where the trust it's the it's
the badness the overall badness that I
don't care about the dress I wear a
dress every day but for a long time from
from what I saw in this documentary and
I didn't actually see the the narrative
film yeah but did he no one would take
him seriously people were just shunned
him they didn't want anything to do with
him and well I think it would I mean
thinking with that would is that Ed Wood
was Atwood because he was two things
that are interesting about it one is
that clearly he was not a very strong
filmmaker I mean in other words his his
judgment as a director was was not there
he was missing that that critical thing
which is he can tell the difference
between when something is bad and when
something is not bad so he was missing
that his writing is it's it's great
because nobody writes like him but it's
not like anybody's gonna compare it
what's writing to f scott Fitzgerald and
and his directing skills were fairly
pedestrian there's nothing in ed woods
shooting that says oh my god you know
he's this guy was a visionary there are
a lot of actually there are a lot of
directors are there a handful of other
directors
working in low budget that were I think
much stronger directors than that would
that don't have the notoriety simply
because they were not as horrible or or
as such a strange personality as that
would write that's what makes him so
interesting but he was also completely
unselfish that he didn't know he thought
he was great I mean he thought he was
doing fantastic work when in fact it was
well it wasn't so I think there was a
reason why you know people didn't take
him seriously because the work was so
weird and and you know to objectively
not good that said it's always his work
has always been interesting that's the
thing because he was like you know he
was sort of crazy in that great way like
he didn't censor himself he just this is
how he saw the world and that's what he
that's what he set down and that's why
why his movies are so distinctive but
they're not technically not even
proficient they're not technically
proficient they're also not technically
artful in any way at all they're just
you know they're just sort of very you
know nuts and bolts kind of you know
moviemaking
you